[Music]
whoa and so we pray
I pray that I don't give up pray that I
do my best pray that I can lift up pray
my brother is blessed praying for enough
pray that you your wins pray I judge
nobody and forgive me my sins I pray we
make it pray my friend to pull through
pray as I take it unto others I do
praying on your love we pray with every
breath though I'm in the Valley of the
shadow of death and so we pray for
someone to come and show me the way and
so we pray for some shelter and some
reest to play so we play we'll be
singing pray that we make it to the end
of the day and shall we pray I know
somewhere that happen this way and shall
we pray I know somewhere that there
something a missing show we play I know
somewhere we'll feel no B until we make
it to the end of the day I pray the Love
Will shelter us on my fears oh I pray
you trust to let me wipe off your tears
confront all the pain that we felt
inside the C to be dealt in life pray
speak my truth and keep my sisters alive
so for the ones who parted SE for the
ones who's following dreams for the ones
who knock down doors and allowed us to
pass down keys speak with a tongue that
is honest and now we understand how to
be modest Pray when she looks at herself
in the mirror she sees a queen she sees
a goddess and so we pray someone to come
and show me the way and so we pray for
some shelter and some records to play
and so we pray we'll be
singing pray that we make it to the end
of the day and so we pray I know
somewhere that happen this way that's
how we pray I know somewhere there
something a Miss that's how we pray I
know somewhere we feel no P until we
make it to the end of the day on the
knees I pray as I sleep and wait cuz
inside my head is a frightening place
keep a smiling face only by this Grace
cuz love more than I can take and so we
pray and so we pray and so we pray and
so we pray we'll be singing by right
nobody's in need
everybody la
la sing it to me la we
[Music]
bre I know somewhere that Happ is
with I know somewhere there something
amazing amazing until we feel no
we PR
we la la la
la
la la la la la we pray we pray we pray
hey gang I hope you enjoyed that flow
session with these brand new uh NG
programmable POI from ignis Pixel and as
I discovered in preparation for making
this video they actually have a us-based
distributor so um you actually still
have time to order a set of these if you
live in the United States and have them
arrive in time for Christmas so if you
have a flow artist on your uh Christmas
list who would like a set of
programmable po these might be a good
option for you uh if you do order a set
please use the promo code Drex factor
that is just Drex Factor no special
characters over at ignis pixel.com
that'll get you a discount on your order
and it helps out the channel so
everybody wins thank you so much to
ignis pixel for sponsoring this video
and yes dear friends there will be a
review on these coming in the new year
so uh go ahead and be on the lookout for
that but in the meantime I do have to
give a quick thank you to the Friends of
the channel uh that is big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys pyrro Tera light toys and Ultra poy
for helping to sponsor the videos that
you see on this channel and make them
possible you can learn more about all of
these amazing companies by checking out
the links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non- buus friend of the
channel that is peka becklen thank you
so very much for supporting my channel
my work and my
mission and of course this video and all
the videos on this channel would not be
possible without my amazing supporters
on patreon and particular I'd love to
give a shout out to my flow patrons who
are listed on screen right now thank you
so much you all rock and if you out
there watching are not currently
supporter but you like the content that
I produce and you'd like to see more of
it the best way to facilitate tape more
of that coming your way is to go and
sign up head on over to my patreon at
patreon.com drexfactor po there you can
get access to a whole host of amazing
rewards but even better than that you'll
be helping me out in my mission to bring
po spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world so go check that out please
and thank you if you want to check out
more of my sponsored flow sessions I
will include a link to a playlist of
those videos down in the description as
well as up on screen for right now
though thank you so much for watching
make sure to get out and flow yourself
today and I'll see you with a new video
very very soon take care peace